combien d'avions s'envolent chaque jour
dans le monde
vous êtes environ 8 millions de
personnes à prendre l'avion
quotidiennement que ce soit par affaire
pour des déplacements personnels ou pour
du tourisme certains aéroports sont plus
achalandée d'autres par exemple en 2013
l'aéroport international d'atlanta
acquis le plus fréquenté avec 94
millions de passagers loin de vente
celui toronto qui ont accueilli 36
millions ou celui de montréal avec ses
14 millions de passagers et ça en prend
des avions pour transporter tous ces
gens au canada 4000 avions cargo et de
passagers s'envolent chaque jour pour
des vols domestiques ou internationaux
à l'échelle mondiale ce sont 90 milles
avions qui décollent quotidiennement
selon l'association internationale du
transport aérien et le trafic aérien
votre continuer d'augmenter on prévoit
que le nombre de passagers va doubler
d'ici 2030